un autre panel ce soir on reçoit michel
c'est roger hélène buzzetti épaules
journée bonsoir à vous deux tabous 3 on
peut parler d'abord de ce confinement
hier on annonçait à ce même bultel point
de presse monsieur legault ce sera mardi
ce sera 17 heures finalement on sortait
des ondes et là on apprenait que c'était
beau pousser ou landes mais qu'est ce
que ça vous dit hall effectivement fois
ce convoi pouces une annonce comme ça de
24 heures et sadique est la décision est
plus compliquée qu'on le prévoyait et
aussi qu'elle sera plus sévère que ce
qui était prévu parce que le
gouvernement compare les eaux à des gens
qui il avait déjà une idée de ce qu'ils
prévoyaient annoncé aujourd'hui par la
suite ils ont jasé à des gens des
établissements de systèmes la santé à la
santé publique puis ils ont réalisé que
la situation était pire que ce qu'ils ne
pensaient que carrément on a perdu le
contrôle et qu'on dirige vers des
décisions extrêmement difficile
l'augmentation du délestage possiblement
des choix à savoir qui on va pouvoir
soigner adéquatement et donc ce qu'on
prévoyait annoncé aujourd'hui n'était
pas suffisant donc on vient avec un
nouveau plan plus sévère et plus les
mesures sont sévères plus elles sont
possiblement controversés ou à tout le
moins plus il faudra bien les justifier
et c'est pour ça qu'on a pris plus de
temps et à ce que je sache que la
décision et pourrait encore changer un
peu d'ici demain à 17 heures va y avoir
d'autres rencontres dans le détail on
sent que des dossiers épineux là dedans
c'est entre autre fermeture ou pas des
écoles est ce qu'on inclut primaire ou
pas ces décisions qui sont vraiment pas
facile de me chasser auger non cette
édition qui sont pas faciles parce que
le gouvernement tient beaucoup à ce que
les écoles primaires c'est possible ne
fermez pas mais je pense que ce sera pas
possible mais ferme le moins longtemps
possible étant donné que ces enfants ont
besoin de socialisation sont vraiment
capables encore de travailler de faire
du télétravail ou de téléapprentissage
s'est pas encore très utile et bien sûr
une question de concept de garde
alors alors donc c'est sûr que l'on veut
garder les écoles ouvertes depuis on a
passé une super de la politique du
gouvernement
quand on a fait d'autres conflits pas ou
si non pourquoi celui du printemps après
50 ans a pris des mesures
nous on est obligé dé fermer pour un
goût ils vont essayer est ce que ce soit
le plus courtois c'est surtout qu'on
entendait juste avant les fêtes et on
lisait ses articles qui faisait écouter
il ya un nombre important d'élèves qui
se dirigent actuellement en situation
d'échec
ça va pas bien il ya ceux qui sont pas
capables de suivre à distance sont pas
capables de maintenir leur intérêt comme
ça et tous ces parents aussi qui ont pas
assez d'ordinateur vous avez plus qu un
enfant tous vos enfants peuvent pas sa
part un ordinateur par enfant
hélène casse tête où ça prend des
solutions au gouvernement une obligation
aussi dire si je ferme je vous
accompagne aussi et puis je vous ai bhl
oui sauf que ça ça fait presque ma foi
dit moore qu'on le dit mais tout à
l'heure par paul parlait de
justification et je pense que ça sera la
clé de l'annnonce de demain vous savez
il commence à y avoir un épuisement dans
la société dans la population
passez moi l'expression n'est qu'un
ressenti aigu les gens sont tannés et ça
plaît aux même l'impression que ça pète
ça sert peut-être arié tout ça on prend
des mesures et il n'y a pas de résultats
et donc demain je pense que la clé pour
le gouvernement sera de d'appuyer
chacune des mesures annoncées par une
justification solide on parle des écoles
ici mais j'entendais des experts dire
constatées notamment que bon considérant
que les écoles ont été fermées juste un
peu avant noël et que les coûts ont
augmenté quand même peut-être que les
écoles ne sont pas un moteur important à
la contamination
alors si le gouvernement veut les fermer
il faudrait qu'il explique vraiment
pourquoi sur tout les jeunes ne sont pas
très affectés par la maladie
on parle peut-être fermer le secteur
manufacturier faudrait une montrer qu'il
ya des éclosions importante et ce fameux
couvre feu dont on entend parler ça
serait une première depuis 1970 la crise
d'octobre
c'est une mesure extrêmement liberticide
il faudrait nous expliquer quel apport
très concrètement travers l'exemple
moi j'habite dans un quartier
résidentiel je vais marchines soir et je
rencontre plein de gens qui courent vont
font leur jogging promènent leur chien
vraiment ces gens là contribuent à la
contamination pas certaine de ça alors
si on veut interdire ce genre de
comportement il faudra le justifier très
solidement services d'avoir une
désolidarisation de démo mais pas je
vous entendent aussi sur cet aspect de
couvre-feu parce que l'information qu'on
a eu jusqu'à maintenant c'est qu'on
irait dans le sens d'un couvre-feu mais
peut-être qu'on donnerait un autre nom
qui fait que ça passerait un peu mieux
parce que c'est quand même très très peu
on n'est pas vraiment de tradition
couvre-feu ici on sait qu'il ya déjà des
gens qui trouvent que juste le masque ça
va trop loin
alors comment faire passer cette idée là
je pense que la meilleure façon de la
faire passer savez de faire des
parallèles avec ce qui fait ailleurs
parce que on a déjà des exemples en
france entre autres en belgique aux
états unis n'ont de montrer que le
québec serait pas le premier à adopter
de telles mesures et de se baser sur
d'autres exemples pour montrer
l'efficacité des couvre feux même si bon
difficile
y aller avec mes liens de cause à effet
mais quand même il semble que ce serait
un outil plus mais je pense que autant
pour le couvre feu que pour les autres
mesures ce qui va être important aussi
pour le gouvernement
ça va être bon s'il demande de nouveaux
sacrifices à la population ça va de
montrer en contrepartie qu'est ce qu'il
fait lui de son côté pour s'assurer tout
ferrand possible pour minimiser les
inconvénients puis avoir la lutte la
plus efficace contre le virus
ça me permet juste de faire un léger
retour sur l'éducation par exemple il ya
des spécialistes qui ont dit si on fait
à nouveau si on prolonge d'école à
distance pour le primaire entre autres
auraient vraiment il y arriver avec des
solutions ciblées du genre mentorat
utiliser des étudiants en éducation
puis leur demander d'intervenir le
activement d'aller auprès des élèves en
difficulté où tous les élèves
donc ce genre de solution et stimuler
autant pour l'éducation que pour les
autres gens qui vont faire des
sacrifices qui seront vraiment pas
facile donc plus de soutien en fait
c'est beaucoup ça plus d'encadrement
peut-être mais michel on peut bien
imaginer ce pas de gaieté de coeur lors
que monsieur legault demain va nous
parler de confinement puis de couvre feu
c'est pas très tentant pour un
gouvernement d'annoncer des choses comme
ça peut-être un tome i les chiffres lui
permettent pas de faire autre chose
actuellement et ça aussi voile expliqué
on est en train de perdre le contrôle de
la propagation du virus de passe on est
en train de perdre le contrôle de ce qui
est en train de se passer dans les
hôpitaux que ça c'est encore plus rare
est ce qu on veut arriver au point où
comme à la sagem aujourd'hui on a dit
aux abois c'est le site passé temps qui
va survivre amené le pôle hôpital est ce
qu on veut arriver là et on n'est pas si
loin que ça de d'une situation comme
celle-là ça je pense que monsieur le
beau milieu de la santé expliqué c'est
ça le problème c'est que ces données le
système de santé ne peut plus
fonctionner pourquoi boris johnson en
angleterre exactement pour cette
raison-là lui disait nietzsche est ne
peut plus suffire à la page mais si on
s'emballe il faut faire plus importante
parlons de vaccination c'est parce que
ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on dira la
lumière au bout du tunnel c'est le
vaccin vaccin il est là mais ce qu'on
voit ce que ça va pas vite
à tel point que sucre d'aujourd'hui
hélène disait écoutez il faut pas que ça
reste à dormir dans les congélateurs le
vaccin une fonction dans le bras des
canadiens ouais je mentionne pas une
exagération aussi parce qu'au départ il
faut garder à l'esprit qu'on a besoin de
deux doses de poule pour le vaccin est
au départ on appris me semble-t-il une
sage décision de par précaution que de
garder la moitié des deuxième dose pour
pouvoir administrer le second piqûre
parle dans un contexte où les
approvisionnements et est très incertain
laon ottawa dit aux provinces est obligé
de garder la deuxième dose parce que on
garantit un certain nombre
d'approvisionnement donc là on va
procéder à l'administration de ces doses
mais moi je ne suis pas scientifique je
veux quand même près passer mes propos
mais je m'inquiète un peu par rapport à
tout ce discours en ce moment que l'on
entend
de reporter l'administration des
deuxièmes noces bien au delà des trois
semaines qui sont recommandés ça
m'apparaît comme une forme de pelletage
par en avant je comprends que dans le
contexte on veut offrir une protection
minimale au plus grand nombre de gens
possible mais on n'y peut rien il faudra
cette deuxième dose est fayez nous
rappeler aujourd'hui qu' il ne peut pas
tester l'efficacité de sa première dose
si on s on n'attend plus que trois
semaines pour administrer la deuxième
alors l'efficacité est à 90% mais si on
reporte la deuxième dose est ce que ça
va descendre 81 66 ou voire 50 pour ça
et je vous donne un petit chiffre il ya
4.7 millions de canadiens qui ont 70 ans
et plus et seulement mois de janvier on
veut recevoir 1.2 millions de doses de
vaccins
donc l'idée là qu'on veut couvrir toutes
les personnes les plus vulnérables le
plus vite possible et c'est pas possible
il faut qu'on accepte le fait que ça
prend deux doses et que sinon il va
falloir qu'on regarde toujours la
deuxième dont jusqu'à atteindre
peut-être un niveau de loyer d'action
bien moindre vous avez à l'écran
justement actuellement leurs tableaux
qui illustrent au québec la progression
des doses alors on voit on est rendu à
trente deux mille sept cent soixante
trois personnes qui ont été vaccinées
alors content je pense 87000 donzelot
qui sont disponibles ce qu'on nous
expliquer ce que c'est très longue
vacciner les groupes à risque en aller
dans chacun des seiches et celle des
sacs chacun des rpa paul ya quand même
une tentation ici parce que le
gouvernement ils sont sous pression ils
veulent vacciner le plus de monde
possible
oui sur l'histoire de ce qu'il fallait
garder une deuxième dose en réserve non
je peux me prononcer là-dessus bon parce
que je suis pas médecin par contre ce
que je peux dire c'est que c'était
pourtant une décision du québec qu'une
exigence de file est la preuve
on a vu la même décision en
colombie-britannique et en ontario et
avec le québec ces trois provinces on
lorsque files ou leur permis ils ont
décidé finalement de procéder de la
façon dont hélène et maintenant pour
savoir si ça va trop lentement comme
monsieur trudeau le disait
j'ai trouvé qu'il était très critique
parce que en ce moment ce qu'on as c'est
vraiment on est au tout début de la
campagne de vaccination est ce qu'on a
c'est un polaroïd et ça varie selon la
journée où on prend l'image je
m'explique par exemple si on était à la
toute fin décembre pratiquement toutes
les doses avaient été utilisés au québec
puis par la suite on a reçu le vaccin
moderna et on avait beaucoup de doses
qui n'avaient pas encore été donné donc
je pense que dans une ou deux ou trois
semaines on sera plus en mesure d'avoir
un portrait représentatif de l'évolution
de la campagne de vaccination de savoir
si elle va vite non puis la logistique
est pas la même pour le vaccin de pfizer
inc
pour l'autre par exemple files heures
une fois que vous ouvrez la boîte vous
devez donner les doses au même endroit
ce qui veut dire que s'il n'y a pas
assez de personnel du ch et ses 2 degrés
amateurs du ch et celle d il faut faire
venir des employés de déplacer le bac
c'est pas la même logique avec le bac 5
de moderne mais je pense que dans une ou
deux semaines peut-être qu'on va
vraiment se rapprocher d'une vaste
couverture de vaccination pour les gens
qui séjournent en 6 h et celle des dans
la région du grand montréal puis en tout
cas si c'est pas le cas on sera plus en
mesure d'avoir une critique éclairée
mais pour l'instant j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'on voit polaroïd
oui je voulais ces dernières qu'elles
secondes michel sur la vaccination
écoutez le gouvernement fédéral chaque
fois que celle de santé le don de se
mettre les pieds dans les classes est
pas lui qui sait qu'ils manipulent les
fringues qui envoie le vaccin dans le
bras déjà et ça prend du temps à partir
la machine on sort on n'est pas encore
au point où on peut dire que la machine
ne fonctionne pas alors laissons le
temps de voir effectivement c'est plus
difficile quand on fait les personnes
mais aussi à celle d honneur pire
qu'après ça la population générale
et bien voila merci d'avoir été avec moi
comme s'asseoir au revoir au revoir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i see her dit